JAMES GRIME: It's like
I'm pulling out beads
on a piece of string.
And as they're pulling taut,
it's unraveling the knot,
which is the story.
If, like me, you're a child of
the '80s, then you'll probably
remember these books--
Fighting Fantasy Books, written
by Steve Jackson and
Ian Livingstone, where you get
to choose your own route
through the book.
So this book isn't broken up
into pages, but rather, it's
broken up into paragraphs,
sections.
And at the end of each section,
you get to choose, as
always, turn to section 282.
Let's look at this section
for a moment, all right?
Section 267--
we're on our adventure, and
we find ourselves at a
crossroads.
It's incredible how often, in
these books, you find yourself
at a crossroads.
And not surprisingly,
we can go north,
south, east, or west.
And then we have to choose which
number we're going to.
So it's not linear.
It's not like I'm going from the
front of the book to the
back of the book.
I'm all over the place.
Ultimately, what we end up with
are battles where we find
ourselves fighting monsters.
As a player, I have skill and
stamina, and if my dice rolls
are high enough, then I defeat
the chieftain, and I win.
And if my dice rolls are too
low, then I die in some grisly
and unfortunate way, which
is normally painful.
I credit these with teaching
me to read, first of all.
So for me, these are a really
pivotal moment in my life.
And so I bought my nephews the
same books when they got to
the same age.
And now they're reading
them, and I'm really
proud of that, too.
But the thing about this book is
we can treat it not just as
a book, but also as
a graph, right?
Now, I'm guessing to most
people, when I say graph,
people think of pie charts
and bar graphs.
But what I mean by a graph in
this case is a set of nodes or
vertices connected by lines to
show you what decisions you
can make at each node.
And we use graphs in maths
for everything.
So we use graphs for showing
how data is connected.
And so when you're writing
computer software, you end up
with, usually, special cases
of graphs like trees for
eliminating data very quickly
from searches.
And so if you want to write a
search algorithm that's quick,
you need a graph.
Or if you're into road traffic
management, and you want to
know how best to flow traffic
around a town, then you want
to make a graph of that
town to show where all
of the roads are.
But what I want to do
is I want to make a
graph of the book.
This book is "The Warlock of
Firetop Mountain." Now,
doesn't that just leap
off the page?
That's fantastic.
You have to start somewhere.
So we'll start at number 1.
That's where these books always
begin with a little
description of the adventure
you're about to have.
And then, at the end,
after a few yards,
you arrive at a junction.
Will you turn west, in which
case turn to page 71, or east,
in which case turn to 278.
And we make a choice.
And I'm going to show you that
choice on the graph.
So I'm going to start down
here, just because it's
closest to me, with a node.
And it's number 1.
We either get to go out
to another node at 71,
or a node at 278.
So now, we immediately
begin to see that the
book branches out.
At 71, we get two choices.
Turn to page 301 or
turn to page 248.
Obviously, with these books, you
spend more times turning
the page than you do actually
reading the page.
33--
and suddenly, we're being
attacked by an orc.
There's a very real
possibility that
we might die here.
So this could be the end of the
story, right, which would
be pretty sad, because we've
only made five decisions to
get to this point.
In that case, you've got to go
back to number 1 and start
again and probably make
different choices.
So it's clear that if I keep
doing this, first of all, I'm
very quickly going to run out
of paper, but it's going to
take a really long time.
And I'm guessing that
you probably don't
want to watch that.
So what I've done is I've
written a little program which
contains every link lifted
from this book.
So every time you get to
make a choice, I've
noted down that choice.
And I'm going to get the program
to draw out the graph.
And the way it's going to do
that is I'm going to start
with each node of the
book distributed
uniformly on the page.
And the ones that are linked
together, they're going to
feel an attractive force, like
a gravitational force between
them pulling them together.
And the ones which aren't linked
together, they're going
to feel a repulsive force, and
so the anti-gravity, right.
So we're going to
have to invent
anti-gravity at this point.
That's going to let the computer
form up the graph
almost organically for us.
Here we go.
There's my big, repulsive force
coming in and showing us
the choices that we've made.
So I'm just going to zoom
in on this start point.
There it is.
Immediately, we make
two choices.
That's what we saw.
And then we follow through on
those choices, and we see the
whole maze just starting
to unravel before us.
By the time we get to this
node right here--
let's just zoom in on that--
every choice that we make
brings us to here.
Now, if I display the numbers,
we find that whatever we do in
this story, if we want to
progress, we have to get to
number 214.
And eventually, we get here to
this enormous maze-- let me
just turn off the numbers so
we can see it more clearly.
As a child, I spent a lot of
time lost in this maze--
the Maze of Zagor.
I always used to find myself
back at the same crossroads
again and again and again.
You might think that this book's
about going and killing
the warlock and stealing
his treasure.
But actually, the point of all
of these Fighting Fantasy
books is to turn
to section 400.
And that's the end.
You know when you see "turn to
section 400," you know you're
finished, because that's always
the last section.
It gives you a warm
feeling inside--
yay, I did it.
And we can see that
right here.
We can see that we make it
through the Maze of Zagor, and
then we're back onto--
just like the start-- a
fairly linear path.
But eventually, we get to
this gold piece, which
is the magic number.
That's 400.
OK?
So I love that.
That's brilliant.
What you will have noticed if
you've been paying attention
is that some of these
spots are red.
I've gone through the book--
with Brady's help.
Thank you, Brady.
I've gone through the book, and
I've made a note of every
place you can die.
And there's a couple of other
points in this book which I
think are quite interesting,
too, and that's that this
node, for example, is black.
Now, a black node is a situation
that you find
yourself in, which, for me,
was always the most
depressing.
Now, let's have a look.
This black node is 118.
So I'm going to look at section
118 in the book.
Now, the first thing we notice
about this section--
and believe me, I got very good
at noticing this when I
was reading these books.
There's no "turn to." We're
not going anywhere.
We've turned to this section,
and we've looked at the
vampire, and he's killed us.
That's why, when I start turning
my way through this
book, my instinct was to leave
my fingers in the decisions
that I made previously, because
then when I get to
section 118, and I'm killed by
the vampire, you can know that
my first instinct is, right,
where was I then?
And straight back to the
previous section to make any
other choice that I could
possibly make.
BRADY HARAN: I can't help but
noticing a few little--
you might have to zoom in on
them for me-- what are those
bad boys down there?
JAMES GRIME: Down here, we
find little clusters like
this, which appear to be wholly
unconnected to the rest
of the story.
And if you don't know Firetop
Mountain intimately, like I
do, then this isn't going to
make any sense to you.
So look away now if you
don't want to know
the answer, all right?
Turn off.
No, don't turn off.
BRADY HARAN: Oh, I know
what we're doing.
If you want to see what happens
there, click on 400.
We'll have a little
"Click on 400."
JAMES GRIME: That's great.
BRADY HARAN: And we'll have a
separate, hidden video where
James explains what that is.
Hi there, everyone.
Just a quick message to let
you know the idea for this
film on Numberphile came from
a conversation with a friend
of mine named Sean, who's
making a feature length
documentary about the guys
who wrote these books.
You can see some of the footage
on the screen there,
on the other side of me.
And in fact, you can see there
one of the actual maps used by
the writers to design their
book, rather than the
retrospective ones that
we showed you.
Now, Sean's film is to be called
"Turn to 400." But to
make it happen, he's trying
to raise money through
Kickstarter.
So if this is a topic that
interests you, and you'd like
to see this other film get off
the ground, please go and
support it.
And I'll put a link underneath
the video.